previously on the walking [ __ ] you but
you're just a scared little girl get the
[ __ ] over it don't feel it all right
another problem huh we could just drive
around you know it works seems likely
because they'll take us right to
Savannah a hundred tons of steel put a
thousand Walker's between us in the
ocean we don't have to give a [ __ ] what
about it look it's something we're gonna
have to deal with you touching my stuff
how's it going right
my name is packaging my stuff I touch
your penis
what disgusting I don't look at me like
that brah hey hey hey don't touch me
you're a zombie and taking Wow I take it
easy I do you raise this man just
because I'm black doesn't mean I stolen
it's no worse for wear
oh yeah I took its water I forgot I'm
sorry your fancy food that your crew
outside yeah and the guy out from the
cab him too yeah I saw you all can do
here I thought about scaring the paint
so how would you scale it I couldn't
force myself can't force yourself then
you're kind of freaking warm to me right
quick and direct sunlight
all right
these things alright
what's going on climbing it's so nice to
me Russia holding duck disappear
invisible duck I know he was the demon
spawn I knew it all along
then Visser bye doc so what's your game
man to keep it alive
all right that's not bad
you bet kitty you're dead man shares my
love of the road thanks duck
what are you doing stop being invincible
I'm sorry to tell you but duck never
existed
thank you we'd like to do the same can
we hold off on them stay with us
we'd like the company yeah it seems
pretty cool for being homeless but I
mean we're all homeless and Doc is
invincible
Oh he plays the guitar that's nice can
remember hearing all right it's doctor
hi girl where is Dutch
just couldn't mean a lot of things right
uh nobody's probably fighting whatever's
in it watch body exactly okay
would you have let Lily Lily back there
my side of the road like that yes Lee
again yeah we have lines
apparently I would have loved her
apparently if you don't leave Lily she
she will steal the band eventually so
that's the climate times that uncertain
eating dango part collier dr. anything
I'm worried about know that little girl
is a puzzle yeah
where did yesterday go yeah things just
go so fast I don't know
are you okay
I'm fine I know you were fond of her
yeah we were gonna get I was I was gonna
get least two I was is this in any term
for you know romance but ya know was fun
yeah [ __ ]
he called her smile best pick-up line he
got in his book oh he's there now he's
there now
all right kind of confused it's like
climbing sweet tastes okay
he was really good no funny aftertaste
no trains cool huh
I guess scary kinda all right
nothing else we can talk about alright I
guess I go to Kenny and we're going to
chain we're cut loose seems that way
yeah great
alright come we don't got much left so
just gather whatever you have let's go
let's go on a train ride girl rode with
a petty girl you got a chain dragging
girl what a ride well it sounds like
you're taking my home yes then and find
anything better for keeping the creepy
crawlies out than that boxcar they could
it be crawling huh ducks sick get on the
train Clementine hey don't talk to my
girl like that let me look at especially
that I hate that little demon spawn
the chain really good idea good idea
what took like that maybe we should
focus on one thing at another yes what
can we do here we get on the train and
we find something better that is the
plane hey hey hey Kenny wants to talk it
through
it's talked through
kenny kenny brack I'll be upfront I
don't want to hear any nonsense until we
get where we're going
Kenny my man
you need it you need a shell pal
all right I guess we're going on the
train then
abduct doesn't samba fie on me if he put
scarlet a little bit of Clementine
endangering I'm gonna kill you I'm gonna
kill ya
that's the throne yes I'll do it then
we got brass it's a train ride
I think Ben is gonna die
he's gonna zombify
it's not good
I don't like this rez that duck kill
that zombies kill that zombie
all right I gotta be hard on adults
taking care of the kids no disrespect
hahaha we're more of a school bus
dad get them
yes why would I lie about that
oh here he comes I need you right no I
need you to go get what sir
my hands are full
oh hey Shay thank you could you just get
that off his face please I'm not tough
to hand
all right we're fine
he's out of time we need to stop this
train okay
holy [ __ ] I just worried about leaving
Clementine alone
I guess nothing gonna happen
geez walk a little slower while you're
at it Kenny you need to stop the tray
I said stop the train breathe I'll make
you Kenny
calm down and how the [ __ ] do you calm
down after a day like today by getting
beat up I talked to your friend Fred
that's right Kenny what is the goddamn
deal he's a little sick but we can't
just quit we're not quite a crach he's
not like the others
Jesus all y'all just making it worse
stop the train stop it god damn it [ __ ]
you [ __ ] you Kenny
knock this [ __ ] off this [ __ ] all I was
wanna talk getting kid relax and talk
you couldn't save her shal son then you
can save duck now shut your mouth
oh [ __ ] like a coward well we are
fighting I didn't really want to fight
Kenny hey I'm not punching you man all
right Kenny that's enough I told coach
I'd get you to stop this you bet your
ass enough today
and now I've had your back don't make me
[ __ ] regret what am I supposed to do
here
that's messages I don't want to hurt
people because it's not break lose a
duck it is not for you because your
[ __ ] lose everything acting like this
I'll [ __ ] kill you before I let that
happen
hey don't kill Kenny
sorry Kenny I really am
you're my bro man
and knock some sense into Kenny all
right
alright yeah that comes read you gotta
do what you gotta do huh
I don't think I've decided in this
moment gotta enjoy it I think it but I
don't like this
the boys been bit g7 figured that out
you trip a lot of him what do you need
man
it's time to it's just not possible
what are we gonna do I don't know we
can't allow him to become one of those
things but what if what if he doesn't
Kenny I love you very much I love my son
more than life itself
I need you to hear me what you are
saying that he may not turn is foolish
but no no it's enough Kenny there's come
on can you think of one you let me know
isn't there some sort of pill or
something we can just give them just
drift off to sleep
Divac any good I mean Jesus this is our
son I know but we know it's here or
nothing
[ __ ] just who then you want me to you
don't have to I'll do it no I don't have
to do it you know it should be a parent
no parent should have to do something
like this ray please right Kat we can
say our goodbyes and just let that be it
I don't know you'd be doing this family
a great service
I'll do it why don't we take him to the
forest
so Clementine doesn't have to see
yeah give us a moment to say goodbye of
course alrighty then
Clemmy it's crazy so many things have
happened so many people have died and
even kids and it's crazy
Jaime I gotta take care of that I'm
gonna take care of that I thought he was
going to die
I'm going to make sure he's in to make
sure he's okay
he's bitten by making sure he doesn't
come back
oh look clear things what what bit why
Clementine into the Train what it'll be
fine
what what in the hell what is going on
right now
did she kill herself yet no gotcha
ah are you kidding me in front of her
son are you why God
oh she crazy [ __ ] god the hell
happened she could
Oh Kenny
Kenya's gonna do it huh
what's going on here
what do we do you know the guys need to
go up here I'll do it
all righty Kenny isn't he gonna say
goodbye
well well well well well if it isn't a
little ducky
you know what duck the first time I saw
you I didn't like you you killed Sean at
the farm you know that right
I know I know
don't worry dad the thing is I don't
want to do this
even though I hate you even though
you're a demon spawn and everyone hates
you I don't wanna do this doc I'll let
you be Robin next time I'll let you be
Robin
poor Kenny
parla little Kenny god damn
that is just horrible I'm depressed now
I thought I would feel good god damn it
I don't know I really don't know I'm
gonna end this episode here I can fairly
be n died somebody things happen all the
time it's crazy but this guy come to
read today the next episode have to do
this come on